(peaceful acoustic guitar music)
- [Interviewer] How would you
describe the Gulf of Mexico?
- Paradise.
- Subtropical paradise.
- Grand Isle was paradise.
- It's a sportsman's paradise.
- Diverse, abundant.
- Strong.
- Resilient.
- Bountiful.
- Beautiful.
- Magnificent.
- Perfection.
- Home.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- I think that we're facing a situation
where there is relatively little oil,
where there is not enough to
warrant the substantial risk.
- Nobody knows how many
millions of barrels,
billions of barrels of oil, and how many--
- Our industries have
pioneered the technology used
in environmentally responsible drilling.
- And they were not
prepared to take the risk.
We are not prepared to take the risk
that the Secretary of
Interior is very focused on.
- And we'll drill for the
billions of barrels of oil
that we have right now
warehoused underground
including our resources offshore.
We will drill here--
- Drill, baby, drill,
and drill now.
(audience cheering)
- So today we're announcing the expansion
of offshore oil and gas exploration
but in ways that balance
the need to harness--
(audience cheering)
- Drill, baby, drill? (chuckles)
Drill, baby, drill!
(crowds cheering)
(explosion thunders)
- [Reporter] 11 workers are
still missing and feared dead
of the rig that exploded
on Tuesday has now sunk,
threatening a major oil spill
off the Louisiana coast.
- [Man] We are at the
beginning of the end,
but there are still a
lot of uncertainties.
- [Narrator] On the
morning of April 20, 2010,
there was a disaster
aboard the Deepwater Horizon drilling rig,
which killed 11 people and
leaked massive amounts of oil
into the Gulf of Mexico.
The Gulf,
which is the lifeblood for so
many hardworking Americans,
had become severely damaged and polluted.
What caused this tragedy?
Who was ultimately responsible?
And how long was it going to take
for this once bountiful ecosystem
to bounce back from
this severe devastation?
To find the answers to
these difficult questions,
we will need to begin this investigation
by taking a closer look into BP's history.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- I believe that the fundamentals of BP,
our strategy, our assets,
and the highest standards of our people,
are something we should all be proud of.
- [Narrator] In 1995, BP hired mergers
and acquisitions guru John
Browne as it's new CEO.
Browne had one mission:
to make BP the largest
oil conglomerate possible
at any cost.
Two years later,
he initiated what was then
the largest merger in history,
the $61 billion takeover of Amoco,
Arco, Burma Castrol, and
several other companies,
making BP the third
largest private oil company
in the world.
It was these mergers
that caused BP to face the enormous task
of upgrading numerous aging facilities,
managing substantial debt,
along with integrating
thousands of new employees.
You might then be asking yourself
how this affected BP's safety culture.
Not well.
In fact, the EPA cited BP
as the largest polluter
in the United States.
This was even more evident when
studying their long history
of disasters.
The list is shocking.
(intrepid thoughtful music)
- Since you took over as CEO of BP,
that safe, reliable operations
are a number one priority.
Correct?
- That is correct.
- And you've been CEO
for the past three years.
Correct?
- Correct.
- Then explain to us why
between June of 2007 and February of 2010,
the Occupational Health
and Safety Administration
checked 55 oil refineries
operating in the US.
Two of those 55 are owned by BP,
and BP's refineries
racked up 760 citations
for egregiously willful safety violations,
accounting for 97% of the worst
and most serious violations
that OSHA monitors in the workplace.
That doesn't sound like
a culture of safety.
- [Narrator] In summary,
in the United States
alone from 1990 to 2010,
BP was responsible for 8000 spills,
217 injuries,
and the deaths of 38 of its own employees.
BP has also been charged
with numerous felonies
and has become infamous
for cutting corners
in order to increase shareholder profits
by any means necessary.
After learning of all BP's
willful safety violations,
deaths, injuries, environmental disasters,
and felony charges,
it was astonishing to
learn of the billions
in US government contracts
they were still receiving.
Why was the United States
government continuing to fund
this blatantly egregious behavior?
To answer this, we must
look further into the past
when the need for domestic oil productions
became much more prevalent
within the United States government.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- Good evening.
The Middle East war produced developments
all over the world today.
The oil producing countries
of the Arab world decided
to use their oil as a political weapon.
They will reduce oil
production by 5% a month
until the Israelis withdraw
from occupied territories.
If the Arab countries keep that pledge,
it would reduce their production
by almost 50% in one year.
- [Narrator] As a result
of US support of Israel
in the Yom Kippur war,
in 1973 OPEC announced that
it would cut production
and place an embargo
on the export of crude
to Western countries.
This caused a global spike in oil prices
unlike anything the world had ever seen.
After the embargo,
consumers were forced to wait
in long lines at the pump.
Station owners set limits on
the amount customers could buy
and frequently ran out of gas.
Regardless of the fact that
America imported less than 50%
of its oil from Arab nations.
During this time, oil
prices increased 330%.
Big oil used the embargo
as political motivation
to open new lands for domestic drilling;
however, this increase
in domestic production
would not bring any real
relief at the pumps,
as the oil companies decided
to keep crude prices high
to maximize profits.
This had a devastating impact
on economies across the globe.
The US responded by
creating a new energy policy
and began to look into
alternative energy solutions.
But sadly, by the end of the 1970s,
the lessons of the oil embargo
were all but forgotten,
and Americans had reverted back
to their previous consumption habits.
Ultimately, the embargo changed the way
the United States viewed its
dependence on foreign oil,
forcing the nation to take a serious look
into drilling in its own backyard.
- [Newscaster] Reagan
is our projected winner.
Ronald Wilson Reagan of California,
a sports announcer, a film actor,
a governor of California
is our projected winner.
- [Narrator] Ronald Reagan
was elected president in 1981.
He made the initial push
to open domestic drilling,
allowing free markets to reign
and trusting that big
industry would act morally.
Under Reagan, the Federal Trade Commission
took on a new dismissive approach
toward corporate mergers.
This environment fostered
the biggest takeovers
in corporate history: Exxon and Mobil,
Chevron and Texaco,
Conoco and Phillips,
and BP with Amoco and then Arco,
creating the largest corporations
in the history of the world.
The mergers allowed Big Oil to resurface
as a major owner of oil
and allowed them to exercise their control
over prices through the futures market,
replacing OPEC as the
principal determinate
of the price of crude.
- Ronald Reagan made promises
that we're gonna deregulate everything,
we're gonna get government
out of your life entirely,
and that private industry
is gonna do a better job,
and we're all gonna be
happy with private industry.
Private industry's gonna be
able to deliver the mail better,
they're gonna be able
to give you healthcare,
they're gonna be able to
take care of your children,
they're gonna be able
to take your prisons,
they're gonna take care
of everything for you.
It was the biggest lie
that has ever been told
to the American public.
- I am suggesting that there
are literally thousands
of unnecessary regulations
that invade every facet of business
and, indeed, very much
of our personal lives
that are unnecessary, that
government can do without,
that have added $130 billion to the cost
of production in this country
and that are contributing
their part to inflation,
and I would like to see
us a little more free,
as we once were.
We have only leased out
and begun to explore 2%
of out outer continental shelf for oil.
Probably 70% of the potential oil
in the United States in
probably hidden in those lands,
and no one is allowed
to even go and explore
to find out if it is there.
- [Narrator] Big Oil also began
taking drilling operations
into deeper waters
where their exploits
became much more risky.
The government downplayed this risk,
and the American public had
been convinced they could rely
on the oil industry to do what was best
for the environment and our way of life.
Reagan would pass the
torch to his number two,
and finally the oil industry
had one of their own in office.
Two months later:
- An oil tanker smashed into a reef
near Valdez, Alaska, today
causing the worst oil spill
since the Alaska pipeline
opened 12 years ago.
- [Narrator] It is interesting
to note that BP owned Alyeska
the company in charge of
the Exxon Valdez cleanup.
By studying the fallout
from the Exxon Valdez spill
and the following cleanup process,
we can get an accurate
idea of what lies ahead
for the Gulf ecosystem and its residents.
- We felt that, by mentioning Alyeska,
people would look into
it and discover, oh, yes,
it was dominated by BP.
So we didn't name those names.
In retrospect, I wish dearly we had
because it could've caused a change
in the internal corporate climate.
Transparency, public attention,
makes a huge difference,
and in the Exxon Valdez case,
the attention was diverted almost entirely
on a captain who had had a few drinks.
- Another think we believed was,
there'll only be short-term
harm in the ecosystem.
We actually questioned
the scientists on that,
and it turned out that that
was based on a 1970s science
that had been done for the Clean
Air Act and Clean Water Act
and the scientists didn't have
any reason not to believe it.
It's sorta like the world is flat
until you suddenly discover
the world is round,
and then everything changes, right?
So everything changed with
the Exxon Valdez oil spill.
The oil that washed ashore
happened to be in the nurseries
for the pink salmon and the herring,
and the fishermen and
the native people said,
"How can this be?
"Here are these little eggs
and here's all this oil.
"What gonna happen?
"So we're gonna wait, we're gonna wait."
We picked four years
because that was when the
herring should have matured
and become adults was in four years,
and it's when the pink salmon,
the ones that survived,
their offspring should
have come back as adults.
One of our questions was,
"What's gonna happen with
those little baby fish?
"Are they gonna be able
to reproduce normally?"
So we picked four years.
And it turns out, in four years,
that's when the ecosystem
collapsed in Prince William Sound.
And all the scientists were saying,
"How can this be? How can this be?"
So the world was all of a sudden round,
and it took the scientists
another eight years
to do all the laboratory studies
and the field studies to sort of validate
the new world order that oil is more toxic
than the scientists thought in the 1970s.
- Basically, herring in that area crashed
and never came back after the spill.
We lost about, estimated
250,000 birds, seabirds,
and we also lost eagles,
quite a few bald eagles
'cause they feed on dead carrion.
So anything oiled was munch time for them.
And we lost a pod of orcas,
and we lost a good many
sea otters as well.
- The one group had brain dysfunction,
and they had short-term memory loss,
and they couldn't concentrate,
and they felt like they
were in a fog all the time.
Then there was another
group that had asthma,
and then another group
with heart irregularities,
and then just general
malaise, chronic fatigue,
just couldn't function very well at all.
A lot of muscle aches, joint
aches, and things like that.
- [Narrator] Exxon spilled
nearly 11 million gallons
of crude into Prince William Sound.
Over 500,000 birds and
wildlife were killed,
and more than 6000
people would be diagnosed
with chronic illnesses
believed to be caused
by the cleanup process.
It was becoming clear that the effects
of this disaster were going
to be serious and longterm.
What is in store
for the Gulf Coast residents
working on the cleanup?
Are they going to experience
the same health issues
in the next few decades
that the Valdez workers
are dealing with now?
This era of deregulation led
to the expansion of power
for Big Oil in the United States.
The interaction between corporate
and governmental agendas
had become blurred
and enabled corporations
to influence elections
and US policy making like never before.
Unfortunately, with the expansion
of lobbyism in the late '90s,
this type of corporate power
and influence would continue
to grow exponentially throughout
administrations to come.
- Basically, this is an
industry that has been dominant
in US politics for a very long time,
but that dominance actually
is only recently been
as strong as it is now in modern history,
and that really began
around the year 2000,
and it really began with
the coming into office
of the Bush administration
in the level of extremes
that we're witnessing right now.
And those extremes are:
the Bush administration
essentially opening up new avenues
of operation for BP or
for the oil industry,
dramatically reducing regulation,
dramatically reducing oversight,
dramatically reducing enforcement.
- [Narrator] The oil
industry spent more money
on the George W. Bush
administration in 2000
than any election in history.
For their generosity,
they received a president,
Vice President,
Secretary of Interior,
Secretary of Commerce,
and Secretary of State
who were all former oil company officials.
This administration
did more than any other
to further the interests of Big Oil
through deregulation, lack of enforcement,
new access to public lands and oceans,
subsidies, tax breaks, and war.
In fact, the revolving
door between government
and the oil industry is all too familiar.
- What we do know is that, basically,
within the first few
days of taking office,
the Bush administration
gave Cheney the right
to make this taskforce.
He was allowed to call
all his best buddies
from his days in the oil industry over,
and not just oil but coal and gas
and all these other fossil fuels.
But they called them over,
and they had all these
series of meetings here
over months to come up with a policy plan
that would go on to guide
then next eight years
of this administration.
This taskforce document
they put out was basically
a wishlist for the oil,
gas, and coal industries.
It was asking for ways
to weaken regulations.
It was asking for numerous incentives to,
among other things, drill offshore.
- You name it, if it was
supervised, if it was overseen,
if it was regulated by
the Federal Government,
Cheney, with his marvelous
bureaucratic talent,
moved in and, essentially,
replaced the people
who were in the positions
that were central to this
regulation, this oversight,
with people who were either lobbyists
for the industry being regulated
or executives from that industry.
- [Narrator] The Bush Cheney
administration enacted one
of the most pro-oil, anti-environment
pieces of legislation
in history, the Energy Policy Act of 2005.
In particular, Section 390 of the Act
dramatically extended the circumstances
under which new drilling
permits could be approved
without further environmental review.
The Minerals Management Service, or MMS,
which is responsible for
the inspection and oversight
of energy companies approved
the project using this type
of categorical exclusion.
In fact, BP was lobbying to expand the use
of such exemptions less than two weeks
before the Deepwater Horizon disaster.
- [Col. Wilkerson] He destroyed
the regulatory mechanisms
in America.
- Give us some examples.
- Cheney left, I'm told,
somewhere around 1600 plus people
in the administration
whom he had converted
from being political or he had
recruited as civil service,
he converted them to civil
service if they were political,
and left them in these positions
that are very key to
regulation and oversight.
And those people will take
a year, a year and a half,
maybe even two years for
the Obama administration
to root out and get rid of.
- [Narrator] It was astonishing
that a federal regulatory
agency was corrupted
so intrinsically by the industry
they were suppose to be regulating.
How could this have happened?
(typewriter keys clicking)
In 1982, Congress passed the Federal Oil
and Gas Royalty Management Act,
which mandates the
protection of the environment
and conservation of federal lands
in the course of developing
oil and gas facilities.
Reagan chose James Watt to be
his Secretary of the Interior.
Watt was a controversial figure,
well known for his
anti-environmental policies.
- It was the Federal Oil and
Gas Royalty Management Act
that set it up,
but it was specifically
to not only exploit
the offshore resources,
but to protect the environment.
And they certainly have done
a good job on the one hand
with exploiting the resources,
but they have done a very poor job
with protecting the environment.
And you have to remember that
all of these resources are
in the common trust,
they're the public trust.
- In spite of the fact
that you read it
repeatedly, over and over,
the facts are not one
lease or well was drilled
in a park or wilderness area
during my predecessor's time
or my time or in the successor's time
'cause it's just not desirable or legal.
- Did anybody go inside one of these?
You know, they were
doing that, weren't they?
Start from the outside
and go in and underneath.
Boy, you were sneaky, gotta watch these--
- In New Mexico we did one
well, and we slant drilled.
They were outside the boundaries there,
and they came drilling in,
snaking that old noodle
right down in there
and hopefully found oil
so we don't have to be so dependent
upon those Persian Gulf states.
I don't want to have America
in a hostage situation
to the Arabs surrounding the Persian Gulf.
- Reagan invented James Watt, OK?
He invented James Watt
because he knew what James Watt was.
He was nothing more than
an ideologue buffoon.
Not only was he not
qualified to do the job,
his ideology didn't
allow him to do the job.
He came from an industry
that hated government.
The mining industry where
he come from around Wyoming,
they hated government
because government was making
them actually pay taxes
for taking our natural resources.
Government was making
them, when they drilled,
do it without destroying
our waterways and our air.
- [Narrator] Watt cut funds
for environment programs
and ensured there would be less regulation
on the federal level.
He had no concern for conservation
and proposed that, by
the turn of the century,
all 80 million acres of US
wilderness become available
for drilling and mining.
- Matter of fact, there's something
that you can go back and look.
It's called the Sagebrush Rebellion.
The Sagebrush Rebellion was
exactly those mining people
and that Western industries,
the Coors family.
It was Richard Mellon Scaife.
It was the Koch brothers.
All of those guys said, "We are
going to change government."
Ronald Reagan was the guy
they put up to do that.
Ronald Reagan was a man
who'd had no history
of accomplishing anything, really.
They put him in office as
governor of California.
This is a guy who sold Borax soap
for General Electric's television.
I mean, what was it?
I forget the name of the show,
but he had some Western cowboy show,
and he sold Borax soap.
So they take this guy,
he has a great face,
he talks well, and we're
gonna put him in government.
And so they put him in government,
but he's their boy, you understand.
Ronald Reagan is corporate America's boy.
And so as corporate America's boy,
they ask him to deliver something:
Take government off our back.
How do they do that?
They create new agencies.
One of them was Mineral Management.
Mineral Management was created by Reagan
for ideologue dimwits like James Watt.
So James Watt, then, does
exactly what we'd expect.
He hires people just like him.
From the top to bottom, they are dimwits.
They're intellectual lightweights,
and more importantly,
they are people who are looking for jobs
because they can't get jobs anywhere else.
I mean, they're minimally qualified,
and every time they're
supposed to be regulating,
what really they're doing is,
they're saying at the dinner table
with this corporation they're
supposed to be regulating,
"Are you gonna give me a job?"
And so the quid pro quo, the trade off is,
if you're gonna give me a job,
I'm gonna let you do what
the hell you wanna do.
- [Narrator] James Watt created
the Mineral Management
Service to be responsible
for the leasing of public
lands for exploration
and collection of oil and gas
revenue for the government,
as well as to ensure that
companies were operating lawfully
and protecting the safety of their workers
and the environment.
The Gulf would be the main site
for deep water exploration,
becoming what environmentalists termed
a national sacrifice area.
Today, 99% of the nation's
offshore oil production occurs
in the Gulf.
The MMS became a partner
to the oil industry.
Because they were so interconnected,
their regulatory authority disintegrated.
MMS officials ignored
environmental reviews,
were lenient in pursuing
companies over equipment failures,
and abandoned proposals that
would have improved safety.
The resulting imbalance of authority led
to a culture conducive to corruption.
- There's a concept in government
called regulatory capture,
and that is that the regulating
agency works so closely
with the industry, they deal
with each other every day,
they start to know each other.
Capture occurs when they deal with,
when they become so comfortable,
that it is the industry that dictates
to the regulatory agency what happens
rather than the other way around.
A lot of people use the phrase
that the regulatory agency
is in bed with the industry,
and they use it as a metaphor,
but you can literally say that happened
with Mineral Management Service
and some of the oil and gas companies
that they were supposed to be overseeing.
The Inspector General
for inspecting the Mineral
Management Service in 2008 found
some really egregious, some
R-rated violations of ethics.
The best quote that I heard
was, "Well, if you're in bed
"with the people you're
supposed to be regulating,
you can't be at arms-length," which is...
Pretty much--
- (chuckles) Sums it up.
- Sums it up, yeah, absolutely.
- [Narrator] The Office
of the Inspector General gave
us a glimpse into this culture
through investigative reports
that tell startling stories
of the Minerals Management Service
and its relationship
with the oil industry.
One investigation found
Director Gregory W. Smith worked
for an outside engineering
firm and used his role
in the MMS to connect them
with industry clients.
He often requested that
subordinates provide him
with cocaine, crystal meth,
and engage in sexual activities.
Another investigation revealed
that MMS employees had accepted gifts
from the oil and gas industry
on numerous occasions.
These are direct violations of
government ethics standards,
and one representative admitted
that business was never
conducted at such events.
The investigations also found emails laden
with sexual innuendoes from
industry representatives,
inviting MMS officials to parties.
There was also evidence
that employees took steps
to keep their social contacts
with the industry a secret.
The investigation uncovered
emails from MMS employees
stating their intendance was
to be, quote, kept quiet,
and that they should RSVP in private.
It was also proven
that MMS employees frequently
consumed alcohol, cocaine,
and marijuana at these functions,
as well as had sexual relations
with oil industry representatives.
- The Minerals Management Service
MMS Lake Charles District:
"We're all oil industry."
The report saying oil industry
officials would fill out
safety inspection reports
themselves in pencil,
and MMS inspectors would
then trace over them in pen
before signing them.
Then there was the inspector
who showed up for work,
still high on crystal meth,
and the other inspector who
inspected four offshore rigs
of a company he was, at
the time, negotiating with
for a job, which he got.
The rigs, meanwhile, got no violations.
And the other inspectors,
who got free lunches from Big Oil,
and other meals, too,
and gifts and golfing
and shooting and hunting trips
and tickets for the 2005 Peach Bowl.
The bigger problem, perhaps not the gifts,
but the suggestion they were unnecessary,
and a revolving door agency
filled with childhood friends
of employees of the oil industry.
A ConocoPhillips employee,
emailing an MMS inspector,
quote, "Ever get bribed?"
"They try all the time."
"Ever take 'em?"
"I accept," quote, "gifts
from certain people.
"But we have very strict ethics standards,
"as you could imagine."
"Certain people?" The
ConocoPhillips employee asks.
"Meaning women?"
"No," the MMS inspector writes.
"Meaning good friends that
I wouldn't write up anyway."
- MMS was asleep at the wheel,
and that needs to be corrected.
They were more of a lapdog
as opposed to a watchdog,
and the fact that BP's plans were approved
when they talked about walruses and seals.
We don't have any walruses
and seals down here.
So obviously either nobody read it,
or somebody read it and didn't
even pay attention to it.
It's probably worse that
they read it and approved it,
You can understand maybe not reading it.
- MMS adopted wholesale
for its oil and drilling
best practices proposals
of the American petroleum institute,
and then they made most
of those best practices only suggestions.
There's been virtually no enforcement.
According to the MMS website,
between 2000 and 2009,
civil penalties averaged less
than $130 per well per year
on our outer continental shelf,
and only three criminal
referrals were made
to the department since
1990, in the last 20 years.
Added all up, and there
is no real question:
MMS was a captive regulator.
- Give 'em some penalties
that will give them
incentive not to do this,
no matter how much money
they get under the table
and all that kinda stuff.
If they gonna go to prison
for the rest of their life
for getting in bed with BP,
you don't let 'em retire with their...
Replace 'em and let 'em retire.
It's been peddled too softly,
and they need some real penalties
on the people who supposed
to be the watchdog.
If they're not the watchdog,
China takes 'em out and shoots 'em.
I don't think we can
do that, but that's...
You need to get serious with those people.
- [Narrator] Finally,
everything was becoming clear.
Deregulation and the government's faith
in big industry spawned these types
of incestuous relationships and
led the government officials
to simply look the other
way while BP operated
at the expense of the American
public and the environment.
(pensive piano melody)
(typewriter keys clicking)
Although the MMS requires
some companies to identify
what they can do to reduce a
project's environmental impact,
the agency grants hundreds
of waivers each year.
It was these types of federal waivers
that essentially gave BP complete control
over its drilling projects.
In fact, just before the
Deepwater Horizon explosion,
a senior director from BP
America wrote to the council,
saying these exemptions
would help the industry
avoid unnecessary
paperwork and time delays.
Traveling further down the coast,
more and more upset residents,
government officials,
and specialists wanted to speak out,
such as Billy Nungesser,
president of Plaquemines Parish.
He is a staunch political force
in Louisiana state government
who had first-hand
experience dealing with BP
from the beginning of this disaster.
He had discovered that BP's
only concern seemed to be
protecting their bottom
line at almost any cost.
- For 11 people who were
on a drilling platform
when it exploded, sending
up a wall of fire.
- The explosion sent six
people to USA Medical Center.
One of them was sent to
the hospital's burn unit.
- This rig is more than 50
miles southeast of Venice
off Louisiana's tip.
- I stood in Venice and listened
to the radio transmission
as they pulled people out the water,
and they kept those men
on the back of that boat for 24 hours.
That's when you knew something
was wrong with this company,
and it was being run
by a bunch of lawyers.
Why'd they didn't bring
those people into Venice?
I was standing by with our ambulances
waiting to care for 'em.
They kept 'em on a boat for 24 hours.
That in itself is criminal.
And it started from
there and went downhill.
- And we read that oil
workers from the rig were held
in seclusion on the open
water for up to two days
after the April 20 explosion,
while attorneys attempted to convince them
to sign legal documents stating
that they were unharmed by the incident,
and then claimed that they were forbidden
from having any contact
with concerned loved ones during that time
and were told that they
would not be able to go home
until they signed the documents
they were presented with.
After being awake for 50 harrowing hours,
Stephen Davis caved in
and signed the papers.
He said most of the others did as well.
Do you think this is an
appropriate way to treat people
that experience that?
- Imagine what it would
have been like to be
in that situation.
So you eventually made it in
the lifeboat to a supply ship
and then back to shore to a hotel,
which is where you were asked
by Transocean to sign this waiver
that I have in my hand here,
which says you were asked...
I was not a witness to the
incident requiring the evacuation
and have had no firsthand
or personal knowledge
regarding the incident.
You put your signature to that.
You were also asked if you were injured,
and you said, "I was
not injured as a result
"of the incident or the evacuation."
Why did they say to you that
they wanted you to sign this?
- They told me...
Me and my wife were actually
about to leave the hotel to come home.
They caught me right before
I went out of the door.
They told me it was
just a statement saying
that I was off-tower,
that I wasn't working,
and I didn't see what happened
leading up to the incident.
Me and my wife were
just trying to get home
to see the rest of our family,
and they said just sign here,
initial here, initial here, sign this.
- Tragedy of the 11 people out there,
many of these people
came from our community.
There was really a human tragedy there
that probably wasn't felt as much
in other parts of the country,
but it was very much felt here.
People knew these people
and grieved with the families.
Initially, the well is
considered pretty far offshore.
It was thought that, we thought,
"Well, they'll get it under control."
They had the blowout preventer on there.
Our hopes were raised every day
and then dashed and raised and dashed,
and I don't know how
many times that happened.
- [Reporter] For four days,
the spill was thought
to have been contained.
All the while, crude oil
was pumping into the Gulf.
42,000 gallons a day are gushing out,
but should the well itself open,
hundred times more crude
could spew into the water.
It could take vastly longer to contain
than previously thought.
- My initial reaction was,
I felt terrible for the
families of the people
who lost their lives on the rig,
and I thought nothing of the fact
that, well, they might not
be able to plug this thing.
I figured it'd be like any other disaster
or any other accident
in that type industry.
A week and a half, two weeks
go by and they plug it up,
and boom it off around the
rig and that's the end of it.
The funerals go on for the
lost lives of the workers,
but I don't think anybody had any idea
what that was gonna lead to.
I was kinda the of the ones,
I stayed real positive.
Once everybody started to kind of realize
just how bad this could possibly be...
I try to stay positive.
That's the only way that
I can deal with things,
and I was thinking, "Oh,
well, maybe it's not,
"it's a natural occurring product,
"so maybe it won't be that
toxic on the environment.
"Maybe there's not near as much
"as they're saying that's leaking."
There's only so much that
you can tell yourself,
and then you go out there
and see that stuff every day
and just thinking, "God!"
We go out there,
and our boat looks like
we've been in a battlefield,
stuff all over the place,
nasty shovels and oil
oil all over the boat.
After a day of doing that,
you're just saying to
yourself, "This Gulf that I...
"My way of life could possibly
be over for a long time."
And that was the hardest
pill for me to swallow.
I had a hard time, after
seeing how bad it really was,
staying positive.
- There are many checks before you get
to activating the blowout preventer.
That is the ultimate failsafe mechanism,
and for whatever reason, and
we don't understand that yet,
but we clearly will as a consequence
of both our investigation
and federal investigations,
it failed to operate.
- In November of last year,
Transocean pulled out the blowup preventer
from the ocean floor because
its shear rams weren't working,
the lower annular would not close
and the upper annular had been stripped
during a well control event.
- This is an annular blowout preventer.
It's actually a 20-inch bore.
The ones used on the
Horizon were higher pressure
and 18 3/4 inch bore,
but there woulda been
two roughly this size
in the blowout preventer stack.
These were primarily the primary,
the main devices used to
actually seal off the wellbore,
either to prevent a
kick or during testing.
And they basically have a rubber elastomer
that can expand and contract
with hydraulic pressure
to seal off the wellbore.
- We know that BP was aware
of this because Transocean,
and again it's document
number 12 there in our binder,
reflect conference calls with BP
about the problems with
this blowout preventer.
- Just before he lands,
he realizes he has not
engaged his landing gear.
So he puts the landing gear,
and the landing gear
doesn't get down in time,
and the plane crashes.
So we have an investigation
on how do we get better landing gears,
and to me, that's what we have here.
We're looking at the
wrong thing, the blowout.
We're spending too much time looking
at the blowout preventers,
and the blowout preventers
are the landing gear.
And what we should be
focusing on is the procedures
that were done.
- As you can see, your engineers said
that if you used a long
string of casing, quote,
"it is unlikely to be a
successful cement job.
"You would be unable to
fulfill MMS regulations,
"and there would be an open
annulus to the wellhead."
I have that on the screen.
Now those are serious risks!
A failed cement job, a violation
of MMS safety regulations,
an open pathway for gas to
travel to the top of the well.
The same document says
that if you use the liner
and tieback approach,
which is what ExxonMobil
and other companies said
you should have used,
you would have avoided
or lessened these risks.
Yet BP apparently overruled the warnings
of its own engineers and chose
the more dangerous option.
How can you explain that decision by BP?
Why were the safety recommendations
of your own engineers ignored?
- I wasn't involved in any
of the decision making.
- To have a blowout,
you have to have a
sequential type of errors,
and what the first thing was,
is that they ran this long
string of pipe in there.
Number two was the
installation of that pipe
and the procedures they used were wrong.
From what I understand,
they were in a hurry,
and they did not wait
for additional centralizers to get there.
- So the experts said you need 21.
Then, and if we can
put up the first slide,
a BP employee essentially
wrote to that expert
and said, "Well, we've only got six,
"and we don't have time to
deal with this problem."
Time to British Petroleum was money.
This rig was 45 days late,
it cost you $500,000 a day,
and people's obvious
attention were about time,
which meant money.
So what happened then?
Well, another British
Petroleum person sent a memo,
saying, "We really need
to follow the model here."
He kicked it up to Mr. Guide.
If we could have the second slide.
Mr. Guide came back and said,
"I don't like the fact the is
gonna take 10 hours to do."
Even though another British
Petroleum person had said,
"We're gonna fly 15 things in.
"They could be here tomorrow morning."
Mr. Guide said, "I don't
like the 10 hours,"
and it didn't happen.
- So what we have is a number of things:
They didn't centralize it,
they didn't circulate long enough,
they ran wrong type of float equipment,
they didn't have enough cement volume,
and the type of cement they
used may not have been correct.
So you have a number of things there.
- Is there any other
well, to your knowledge,
in the Gulf of Mexico that has been done
in the same manner as this
well that was being drilled
under the Deepwater Horizon?
- There are many wells
in the Gulf of Mexico.
- Are there any other wells
where you haven't put the proper
number of centralizers in?
- There are many wells
in the Gulf of Mexico
that have the same casing design.
There are many wells
that have been drilled
where the same cement procedure has been--
- Now have the Minerals and
Management Service people
been there and looked over
those with a fine tooth comb?
- Everything that we do is
subject to regulatory oversight.
- Are you changing your
procedures at those wells
as a result of things
that you've encountered
in your investigation with the Deepwater--
- As we learn, apologies.
As we learn from our investigation,
we will make appropriate changes,
as I've already indicated.
- The potential devastation
to the Gulf Coast,
its economy and its people,
require us to continue
our relentless efforts
to stop the leak and contain the damage.
There's already been a loss of life,
damage to our coastline,
to fish and wildlife,
and to the livelihoods of everyone
from fishermen to
restaurant and hotel owners.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- The fact that they
had even less confidence
in where this oil was heading told us
that we need to have a sense of urgency,
and we need to start working
to protect ourselves.
We had our first impact on May 12th,
three days after declaring emergency
with tarballs hitting the beach,
and then seven days later we
had our first major impact,
with heavy brown crude
oil ending up, basically,
scattered most of the 12 miles of beach
that we have here in Fourchon Beach, so.
- It was so unbelievably different
from one day to the next.
It was just a joke.
We had different bosses every day.
We had different people
we were answering to.
We had different partner boats,
different people on our taskforce.
We would just get trained
at doing something
and felt like we were
like, "OK, we're trained.
"We're adequate to do this job,"
and then they'd tells us
to go do something else.
Tell us, "Hey, why don't
you go check on that boom."
"We're getting pretty good
at picking up this oil.
"Why don't you let us keep doing this?
"We'll keep out waters clean."
"No, we need you over
here checking this boom,"
after 67 other boats
have already checked it.
So it was like that every
day, I mean, then...
Oh, I could go on about getting paid,
and "Oh, you're gonna
get paid within a week
"after submitting your invoice."
Yeah, my ass.
The whole thing was just a debacle.
- BP came in here,
and they put me out of
the shrimp business,
they put me out of the coast business,
they put me out of the retail business
'cause they took our tourists away.
They put us out of the ice business
because we make 130 tons of ice a day,
and if the shrimp ain't
running, they don't need no ice.
And the only thing we had
left was the fuel business,
and BP brought in outsiders
from Texas and parked a barge.
They don't pay no taxes over
here, don't pay nothing.
I mean, I asked them if they
wanted my dog and my wife, too.
You might as well take everything I got.
- The oil showed up.
I can't fish right now.
There's a saying that I do what
I do best, and that's fish.
Do what you do best and pay for the rest.
A good friend of mine
told me that years ago,
and it's kinda stuck in my head.
That's what I do, I am
a charter fisherman.
- This is what you call not
a disaster, this is a...
I don't know what you want to call it,
but this is the worst
that could ever happen,
and it's not just us.
Hey, we got people from
Mississippi, Alabama.
Florida, Florida, we have a
lot of people from Florida
that come fish off a here,
king mackerel and snapper,
that fishes here, too.
Mississippi comes over here to shrimp.
So, and it's not just Louisiana
that's gonna be affected.
We have people from Texas come here
just to work these areas.
It's everybody that's gonna be affected
with this oil spill, everybody.
- The oil spill hit at
the absolute worst time
for our community.
The businesses we have here are all local,
family-owned businesses.
We don't have very many,
if any, big corporations
that are set up in town operating.
And so they, really, throughout
the summer bank their money.
That's when they earn the money.
There's about a hundred days of summer.
We try to sneak through the
fall and over the winter
and kinda get by until spring break.
This year, 2010 spring break
season, was a breakout year.
We had good growth, we had
8% or 9% growth in tourism.
We had good money flowing in.
People had, after the
different hurricane seasons
that we had had and had some
rebuilding and some growth.
Then we had a downturn in the economy.
All of a sudden, this
seemed to be the year
where it was up-ticking.
And so, before the season
started, which is really,
our Memorial Day starts our summer season.
Before it got here and ever got started,
we had the brakes put on and
struggled all summer long,
and now I'm hoping that
the businesses can survive
through the winter, through
another down period,
and be prepared in springtime.
So we're fighting not
necessarily for 2010 anymore.
Now we're fighting to survive
to get to 2011, next year,
to make sure that the businesses
that are here can be here next year.
- There was double-digit
decline in business, some 20%.
Some of the real estate
folks were down 30%.
These businesses in Pensacola thrive
on a June, July, August vacation period.
That's when they make their money.
That's when they save their money
to make it through the rest of the year.
And that business was down appreciably,
and there were some
businesses that were saying,
"We don't know if we can make it."
- It bothers me that they'll
hire people from out of town,
out of state and won't hire me.
This is my living, this is my way of life.
I want it back.
(exciting music)
- Larry, thanks very much.
Breaking news tonight,
potentially chilling news.
A leading expert, who you'll
hear from in a minute,
has examined this video of oil gushing
into the Gulf of Mexico,
and what he says is horrifying.
The leak, which the Coast Guard estimates
at 5000 barrels a day, could
be far worse, 10 times worse,
and that's the bottom end
of his estimated range,
which means that this
expert is talking about
at a bare minimum, about the equivalent
of one Exxon Valdez spill every four days.
- I think they lied
about the amount of oil
that was going into the Gulf immediately.
I will say that: L-I-E, lied!
They knew that more oil
was going into the Gulf
than they first admitted, OK?
Their efforts to cap the well,
their efforts to do this.
Whatever, that's all fine and dandy.
All in all, I wasn't very happy with BP.
- And there's an area
called Barataria Bay,
and I would suggest you go look it up.
About a week and a half ago,
there was no oil in Barataria Bay.
That section was scheduled to
be covered by the barrier plan
that still to this day
hasn't been approved.
Now today, there's oil, thick
oil coming into Barataria Bay.
And so you're not showing
the sense of urgency,
and whether it's you or
the Federal Government,
we've got oil in Barataria
Bay when we had a plan
a month ago to keep the
oil out a Barataria Bay.
And so when people are hearing
that everything's being done,
I'm a tell ya, on the ground,
it's not getting done!
And I don't know what you
need to do differently,
but you need to go do
something differently.
And if it's not you that's blocking it,
you need to tell somebody
who's blocking it
because it's being blocked,
and it's not getting done on the ground,
and we don't have the luxury of time.
This shouldn't be happening.
- After the storm, they were
bringing boom out to safety.
Then last night, they were
bringing the same boom out
because it was the defective Chinese boom.
So what is it?
- What?
- We were lied to.
We continue to be lied to,
and I told the second commander
who I just came from meeting with,
I just told her everything,
I don't hold back.
And she says, "Well, I
don't expect you to trust me
"by saying it, I need
to show you by action."
I said, "You absolutely do."
And I said, "From this moment
on, you have an opportunity.
"Here's my phone numbers.
"For any equipment moves in this parish,
"I deserve a phone call,
so there's your chance."
- After it became obvious we
were gonna have to deal with it
then the focus and the working
relationship with BP was,
how do we deal with it?
How do we clean it up?
How do we get it skimmed
before it gets here?
How do we protect our backwater areas?
You know, that kind of
working relationship,
which started off pretty rocky
because they had transitioning
people in and out
before they ever have anybody
permanently located here.
And we were dealing with one guy one week,
and they'd take a two
week reprieve and be gone,
and we'd be dealing with somebody else,
and there was no consistency.
- I felt like we were
completely in the dark.
No one knew anything.
Scientists didn't know anything.
You couldn't get any
information out of anyone
that you thought should know something.
I mean, I worked at Hopedale
when they were just setting
up the volunteer system,
and no one there knew
anything that was going on.
I mean, you'd walk to the
Fish and Wildlife trailer,
and they didn't know what was going on.
It just really was blank, it was a blank.
- And I said, "Houma.
"Still don't know who I call at Houma.
"The Wizard of Oz,
(interviewer chuckles)
"and some man hiding behind a curtain."
There's nobody, they still
couldn't give me a name.
"Well, I'll find out who in Houma."
Say, "Well, when you do, let me know,
"'cause we'll travel that
yellow brick road together."
Because I can't but for the life of me see
how a town a Houma can
make so many decisions
without having a name behind it.
- Communications were
not what they should be.
I think everybody would agree to that.
The Unified Command, of
course, was over in Mobile.
And what our premise was,
that we in Pensacola knew our beaches,
we knew our bays, we knew our bayous,
we knew how to take care of them.
Let us have more control.
But all the control, all the
requests had to go through
that particular chain of command,
and it took a long time, and
it was very, very frustrating
because as I said before,
we knew we had this horrible problem,
but there were so many questions
as to how to combat it.
It was a huge unknown.
- With BP out of the way, it
would raise the question of:
Replace them with what?
- [Reporter] Only BP, he
said, has the equipment
and expertise to plug a leak
a mile below the surface.
The government does not.
And he said he's still confident BP,
with aggressive pressure
from the government,
will get the job done.
- You know what Allen told me yesterday?
"I'm 51% in charge."
Are you a little pregnant?
Do you kiss your sister?
I mean, what's 51% in charge?
Either you're in, what
kinda leader tells you,
"Hey, look, we're going
into war, but I'm 51,
"if you get shot, that's on
the 49% that ain't in charge."
If we win this...
I mean, how do you tell the troops,
"Hey, guys, let's go fight
this war, I'm 51% in charge."
It's a business deal.
- Now we are operating six
remote-operated vehicles
simultaneously around
the blowout preventer,
both monitoring the blowout preventer
and trying to close in the flow of oil.
Development driller
three is now on location,
and we expect to start
drilling the relief well
within 48 hours.
Also, a new technique
identified yesterday afternoon,
which is to try to deploy
dispersants at the source,
at the location subsea.
- Well, what they told us was,
the dispersants would break it up
and make it sink to the bottom
and it wouldn't come ashore,
that I was being paranoid, and
it wasn't gonna come ashore.
It was gonna stay off shore.
And three weeks and four
days from that time,
Pass a Loutre got inundated with oil.
And I went back out five days in a row.
Then on the seventh day,
I brought Anderson Cooper
and the governor out there,
and a week later, I brought
Anderson Cooper back,
and still nobody did anything,
and then the third week, still.
It was almost a month
that oil sat out there
with birds dying in the oil.
All the fish in that area died.
There was no life in that marsh,
and that marsh is dead.
It'll wash away,
and South Louisiana will start
about a half mile inland.
That marsh will be gone next year.
- In the Dictionary.com
definition of disperse,
one, to drive or send off
in various directions,
to scatter.
Definition two, to spread
widely, disseminate,
to dispel, cause to vanish.
So really what they're doing,
if you get to the core of this,
and keep me honest on this.
But really what they're doing
is making us not be able
to see the disaster that is in our gulf.
They're not fixing anything.
We just can't see it anymore.
- The difference here is
that we have put these surfactants out
at unprecedented quantities.
It's an open ocean spill.
The other unprecedented part of this is
that we've put surfactants
at the wellhead a mile down in the water,
so we have dispersed oil
through the entire water column.
Now what was misleading
about what EPA has been coming out with,
they said that oil and
oil plus dispersants,
there's no difference in
toxicity of these two.
The difference that they're glossing over,
that's technically true,
that oil and oil plus dispersants
have the same toxicity,
or similar toxicity on a concentration
per concentration basis, right?
They have similar toxicity.
The difference is, the bioavailability,
and this is what was misleading
about the pronouncements
where they keep saying
over and over again,
the government's saying
that there's no difference
in the toxicity of the oil
and oil plus dispersants.
What that glosses over is that,
with the oil plus dispersants,
you have increased the bioavailability,
which increases the toxic effect.
It doesn't necessarily
increase the toxicity
of the molecules, but it
increases the toxic effect
because it increases bioavailability.
- Our workers, our fishermen went out
and worked on the oil spill response,
and they were told, "Oh,
the oil is nontoxic.
"It's gonna be as safe as pancake syrup."
And people got sick.
People were coughing,
headaches, dizziness, nausea.
It's like a TB ward out there.
I mean, everybody's hacking
and choking and coughing.
What is going on?
And I say, "Well, I don't know,
"but surely the medical doctors
will take care of this."
And again, this is another example of,
we trusted the medical community.
We trusted the federal and state laws
that are put in place to protect workers.
And it turns out there
was loopholes driven
into all those laws by the oil companies
and by the petrochemical industry
so that those laws all missed
that the workers were sick
because of oil from the Exxon Valdez
and the chemical
dispersants that were used.
So no, nobody took care of them either,
and I still am dealing
now with cleanup workers
from the Exxon Valdez 21 years later,
who are saying, "I thought I
had the Valdez crud in 1989.
"That's what Exxon told us,
"just a little cold, a little flu.
"I didn't think I'd have it for 14 years,
"18 years, 21 years.
"What is wrong with me?"
- [Narrator] Hearing story after story
of BP's immoral,
profit-motivated operations
and the accompanying negligence
that caused the explosion,
which claimed 11 lives,
the human effects of this spill
were becoming more apparent
on a visceral level.
- Whenever I heard
that they were cleaning
the oil spill in the Gulf,
I realized that it was
deja vu all over again.
It was me and my crew out there cleaning
and becoming sick, not
being able to breathe,
and suffering with the flu-like symptoms,
with stomach disorder.
It would become like bronchitis,
and when we went to the
doctor, they only said,
"It's the flu, and it's going
around, and everyone has it."
- More and more stories
about sick fishermen are
beginning to surface.
They're out in the Gulf, many
of them all day every day,
working to clean up the spill.
Many blame the chemicals BP is using.
One fisherman told me tonight,
he felt like he was going
to die over the weekend.
- Like a (scoffs) sniffing
gasoline or something.
And I still, with my ears
are popping right now.
I'm still coughing up stuff.
I feel real weak, little tingling.
- [Reporter] Marine
toxicologist Riki Ott says,
the chemicals used by BP can
wreak havoc on a person's body
and even lead to death.
- With the volatile organic carbons,
they act like a narcotic on the brain,
and at high concentrations,
what we learned at Exxon Valdez
from carcasses of harbor
seals and sea otters,
it actually literally fried
the brain, brain lesions.
- [Reporter] Congressman Charlie Menancon
wants something done.
He sent a letter to the
Obama administration,
calling for temporary
healthcare clinics to be set up.
- [Congressman] Close by,
so that there can be immediately attention
to any people that feel
that they have problems,
adverse problems that are
caused by the inhalation
or exposure to the oil.
- According to testimony
we heard in Louisiana,
still BP failed to provide respirators
to the workers exposed to the crude oil,
and the workers
experienced health impacts.
The workers were afraid to
speak up due to the potential
to lose their jobs.
Those fishermen who
attempted to wear respirators
while working were
threatened to be fired by BP
due to the workers using the respirators.
Do you know anything about that?
- I'm not aware of that.
- [Reporter] Now the federal
Environmental Protection Agency
has been tracking what's in the air
by using a mobile truck and
seven monitoring stations,
located mainly in St. Bernard
and Plaquemines Parishes.
They are looking for evidence
of several compounds,
including hydrogen sulfide and
volatile organic compounds,
or VOCs, like Benzyne, which
we commonly know as swamp gas.
A normal level ranges from
five to 10 parts per billion.
At the Venice station on May 2nd,
the levels recorded were
30 parts per billion.
The next day, the reading
was nearly 40 times that,
at nearly 1200 parts per billion,
and the day after that,
it dropped down to 46
before rising the next
day to more than 1000.
- The air quality's not good.
We've been having trouble, you know.
I've been seeing people sick,
their eyes crying a lot,
nasal passages stopped up, sore throats.
I don't think it's safe.
My wife just refused to leave.
- My daughter got sick.
- How old is your daughter?
- It was my daughter, she's 14.
We took her to the emergency room.
She was having a headache
real bad and all the time,
so we took her to the emergency
room and they did tests,
and they couldn't find
nothing wrong with her.
And the doctor said, "Follow
up with another doctor"
"if she still had 'em,"
so she still had 'em.
So we took her to another doctor,
and they drew blood and they...
and they found chemicals
in her urine and all,
different kind of chemicals.
- [Reporter] The president
also came here as a salesman,
to convince vacationers to come on down.
- Beaches all along the
Gulf Coast are clean.
They are safe, and they
are open for business.
That's one of the reasons
Michelle, Sasha, and I are here.
- News 5 is doing some testing of our own.
News 5 investigation
took us from Gulf Shores
to Orange Beach to Katrina Key
to the Dauphin Island Marina.
We collected samples of water, sand,
and when we saw kids digging:
Do you mind if we get some water
out of your sand hole here?
We got a sample of that, too.
Bob Newman is a chemist with
nearly 30 years of experience.
He tested our water and
sand for oil and petroleum.
Gulf Shores beach water, right
where people were swimming,
showed 66 parts per million.
And the sand where beach-goers are walking
has 211 parts per million.
The sixth sample was a spot
in Orange Beach where, again,
we found kids playing,
and we found our highest
content of oil and petroleum,
221 parts per million.
But the tests didn't stop there.
The sample we haven't
yet told you about is
the one collected from
Dauphin Island Marina.
The sample exploded right in his lab.
- Almost instantaneous,
actually maybe one second.
It's just weird.
- [Reporter] The result
surprised even our chemist.
- We think that it most likely
happened due to the presence
of either ethanol or methane gas
or the presence of the
dispersant that corrects it.
- Across the Gulf, there
were stories of sick people,
I mean, emergency room,
puking brown, peeing brown.
This is internal hemorrhaging.
This is what the EPA whistleblower
Hugh Kaufman was talking about.
This is what the material
safety datasheets talk about,
internal hemorrhaging.
- I think that the use of
dispersants is criminal.
I mean, essentially, by
allowing BP to use dispersants
rather than forcing them to
come and skim and remove the oil
from the top of the Gulf surface,
we have legally allowed
them to use the Gulf,
our gulf, as their disposal unit for oil.
Dispersants don't make the oil go away.
They simply make it smaller,
they make it dissolve into the water,
they make it break down
to where, it's true,
to where oil-eating
microbes can break it down
at a faster rate, absolutely true.
But what it also means is,
the other billions of
organisms in the Gulf
that aren't oil-eating
microbes can also absorb it
and bioaccumulate it
at a much faster rate.
There are many studies after Valdez,
for a decade after Exxon
Valdez and the overall message
from all of these peer-reviewed
scientific studies was,
dispersants, including Corexit,
increased the bioaccumulation of the PAHs,
the carcinogenic component of oil
by anywhere from 12 to 50,000 times.
So our laws are set up to
where BP was allowed to dispose
of their oil into our gulf's
food web, essentially.
Big mistake.
- News report that they had,
it said that the snapper
and mullet were safe to eat.
Well, you can catch snapper in this bay.
Snapper and mullet were safe to eat,
but shrimp and crabs, stay away from 'em.
They're all habitat in the same bay.
Nowhere else, they're in this bay.
I mean, if you wanna say,
"Well, how can snapper and mullet be safe
"and shrimp and crab side-by-side,"
I mean, literally,
side-by-side, they're not safe.
Something don't make
sense with that picture.
That picture doesn't sell with me at all.
If that was meant to be said,
and they said it that way, they're wrong.
And I still wouldn't sell anything
until all of these species are safe.
- The dispersed oil is
gonna affect all of that.
It's gonna affect the
eggs, the larvae, the food,
everything in the plankton
is gonna be impacted.
And so that area that's
been affected is...
You can't, probably shouldn't
go as far as saying sterilized
but, I mean, the impact is huge.
- My livelihood, the money
that I live off of comes
from selling fish and stuff.
Yeah, I want it to be open,
but would I personally
eat anything that I catch?
I certainly have my doubts.
I would be a little bit apprehensive.
- We expect to see a substantial reduction
in the overall amount of dispersant used,
primarily because they
shouldn't need to be spraying it
if they're able to disperse it earlier.
If we start to see dispersing
chemicals in that water
or anywhere in the water column,
we're gonna recommend strongly
to the on-scene coordinator that we stop.
- It was everywhere.
Obviously, certain days
would be worse than others,
depending on how strong
of a south wind we had
or what the current was doing.
As I've said before, it was weird how,
being a fisherman and knowing
the Gulf like I feel I know it
knowing what direction and
how fast the current's moving
and what the wind's doing, I mean,
there was absolutely no rhyme or reason
to being in the stuff for
two weeks straight everywhere
and knowing that there was a
bunch of it to the east of us
when we've got a current out of the east,
and it should be just right
over here the next day
and it's gone, just little white bubbles.
We heard rumors, and I can't confirm it,
but I mean, there's not doubt
they were sinking the stuff.
They were spraying it
with airplanes at night.
I've got some friends, I'm
not gonna mention their names,
but they worked offshore, stayed offshore
for several days at a time
and they would tell 'em,
"Between 12 and four, stay in your cabins
"because we're gonna bomb
it, we're gonna spray it."
From my understanding, that was not legal.
That was not authorized by the government
for them to do that, they did it anyway.
Out of sight, out of mind
has been their policy,
and they lived up to that part of it.
- The BP lied from day one,
and they're still lying to people,
so what's the difference?
We ask them to quit
spraying that disperser
'cause that's a killer, but
they wanna keep on hiding it.
They keep on spraying,
they wanna hide that oil
under the water where nobody can see it,
which is wrong.
Let the son of a bitch come
to the top of the water.
Let them skim it.
- I've been on record
for a long time being
against use of that dispersant.
I'm not against use of a dispersant.
There's a lot of organic dispersants,
and that's what I was
talking about earlier.
People can't get their products
to BP to be considered.
I've seen a lot a organic dispersants
that, one, coulda been used.
I have a problem with
the dispersants they used
'cause it's Corexit.
There's corporate relationships between BP
and the company that manufactures Corexit.
It's banned in the United Kingdom.
If it's not good enough
for the United Kingdom,
it shouldn't be good enough
for the Gulf of Mexico, number one.
Number two, I think this
dispersant may be...
The solution may be
worse than the problem.
And three, the dispersant
has actually complicated
the skimming of this oil because
it's forced it underneath
and it's also been like
trying to track a ghost.
Again, I think the Federal
Government failed us there
because, again, just like we talked about,
for MMS now the department
of ocean and energy,
the EPA has been basically
a lapdog and not a watchdog
because they've requested
and they've said on record
they have told BP not to
use it, but guess what.
They continue to use it despite that.
- EPA told 'em, stop using it
because it's toxic to human beings.
BP said no.
- Right.
- Now we've learned there's
not anything else out there
in the kind of quantity they need.
So they're putting something
toxic to human beings
and harmful to sea life in the sea?
- You know, what's interesting,
Shepherd.
- Not to me!
- An Exxon report some years ago showed
the Corexit is actually
four times more toxic
than the crude oil itself.
- Would you say that again?
- In this case, these
dispersants were used
in massive quantities, almost
two million gallons so far,
to hide the magnitude of
the spill and save BP money.
And the government, both
EPA, NOAA, et cetera,
have been sock puppets
for BP in this coverup.
Now by hiding the amount of spill,
BP is saving hundreds of millions,
if not billions of dollars in fines.
And so from day one, there was
tremendous economic incentive
to use these dispersants
to hide the magnitude
of the gusher that's been going
on for almost three months.
One thing that I did
wanna mention to you, Amy,
that's occurred in most investigations,
back even in the Watergate
days, people said,
"Follow the money," and that's correct.
In this case, you've
gotta follow the money.
Who saves money by using
these toxic dispersants?
Well, it's BP.
but then the next question,
I've only seen one
article that describes it,
who owns BP?
(intrepid pensive piano music)
When you look and see who owns BP,
you find that the majority ownership,
a billion shares is a
company called BlackRock.
Vanity Fair just did recently an article
about Mr. Fink and his
connections with Mr. Geithner,
Mr. Summers and others
in the administration.
So I think what's needed,
we now know that there's a coverup.
- [Narrator] It was becoming obvious
that Americans could
no longer blindly trust
their watchdog agencies.
- Today the Federal
Government is releasing
a new scientific analysis
that addresses the question:
Where did the oil go?
The key conclusions of the report is
that the vast majority of
the oil has either evaporated
or been burned, skimmed,
and recovered from the
wellhead, or dispersed.
And much of the dispersed
oil is in the process
of relatively rapid degradation.
A significant amount of
this is a direct result
of the very robust
federal response efforts.
- New evidence has badly shaken
the Obama administration's rosy narrative
about the alleged disappearance
of most of the oil
that gushed into the Gulf of Mexico
from BP's blown out well.
Early this month,
the report by government
scientists declared
3/4 of the oil had vanished,
either collected or dispersed.
But numerous reports contradict
the administration's sanguine
picture of the cleanup effort.
Researchers at the
University of Georgia said
about 3/4 of the oil is still
lurking below the surface
of the Gulf and may pose
a threat to the ecosystem.
Separately, a study released last week
by the University of South
Florida scientists found oil
and sediments of an underwater canyon
and evidence that the oil has become toxic
to critical marine organisms.
On Thursday, a team of researchers
confirmed the existence
of a vast underwater oil
plume stretching 21 miles
from BP's blown out well.
Christopher Reddy of Woods
Hole Oceanographic institution
said the amount of oil
in the plume is unknown.
- [Narrator] Now it was
clear, how and why BP,
with the help of the Federal Government,
willfully caused this disaster
and continually tried
to sweep this toxic soup
under the rug.
- I don't care if you're
a Democrat, Republican,
Independent, Green Party.
Look, let's face it.
They dropped the ball in
not protesting these toxins
or these dispersants
being spread in our water.
We don't know the longterm effect.
- [Narrator] If that wasn't bad enough,
the desperate out-of-work Gulf
Cost residents were forced
to do the hazardous sweeping
without proper safety geer.
The final insult was the cleanup
workers gross underpayment,
which leads us to the last
subject: compensation.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- The only way you intend
to pay those claims is
if it comes through this fund.
Is that your testimony today?
- $20 billion is a very large
sum of money to pay claims.
- I'm sorry?
- $20 billion is a very
large fund to pay claims.
- It is a large fund, and is it your view
that part of what that
fund will be used for is
to pay people for their
longterm healthcare costs
incurred as a result of this spill.
- That will be a decision for
the independent adjudicator.
- Well, if they asked
you what you thought,
would you say, yes,
the healthcare costs should
be paid for from this.
- I think that's something that
I will leave him to decide.
That's why we've appointed
an independent adjudicator.
- So...
- He's the guy that settled
all of the Agent Orange suits
from the Vietnam War.
He's the fella that was the
trust fund administrator
for 9/11 after the collapse
of the World Trade Center,
and you can imagine how
complicated that was,
especially with all of the deaths
that occurred from that tragedy.
He is the fella that was
called upon to Virginia
in the Virginia Tech Massacre
to solve those problems.
Here we have the world's expert to step in
and smooth out this process and to see
that just and due compensation is given
to people who have suffered as
so many of us have suffered.
Ken Feinberg.
(audience applauds)
- I wanna thank Senator Nelson.
I'm here because Senator
Nelson said, "Be here,"
and when Senator Nelson
asks you to do something,
you do.
- What's going to happen to our fish,
our crabs, our shrimp, our oysters?
People are not buying our seafood now
because of these toxins.
How can British Petroleum
make us whole on that issue?
- You seem to be saying
that our oysters,
that there's gonna be longterm,
potential longterm devastation
to the ability to catch quota.
I don't know if that's true.
Do you know if that's true?
There may be no longterm impact.
Senator Nelson mentions my credibility,
doing these other projects.
My credibility will last
a very, very short time
if the money doesn't get delivered here
to eligible claimants
beginning when I take over
with the Gulf Coast claims
facility on August 23rd,
less than two weeks away.
- [Reporter] BP has
pounded home this message:
- [Man's Voice] BP has
got to make things right.
- And they're spending
$100 million on a PR blitz
to tell the rest of the country
they're making us whole.
Guys, it's not true, it's not true.
- [Reporter) And Mayor Kennon
Of Orange Beach, Alabama,
devastated when tourists stayed away,
says the new independent
claims administrator
Ken Feinberg has not made things better.
- So we're very upset with
the overall performance
of Ken Feinberg.
- [Reporter] In an interview,
Feinberg acknowledges problems.
- We haven't processed all of the claims
as quickly as we should've.
I oversold this program at the beginning,
and I'm paying the price for it.
I do not work for BP.
- I'm still sitting over here.
They cut me instead of helping me.
They cut me from 5000 to 2300 a month,
so you tell me.
(typewriter keys clicking)
- What's happened with,
and it's not just the BP scenario.
It happens across the board.
In America, we have this,
because we value capitalism so much,
and capitalism really is a great system.
It's potentially one of the
best systems in the world
but has become so
remarkably flawed lately.
Part of the flaw is that the people
that you talk to along the coast,
probably if you ask 'em what their sense
of corporate America is,
they don't really see them
as criminals sometimes.
Now if we dress 'em up in an Armani suit
and we put $500 shoes on 'em,
and we put Rolex watches on their hands,
and we put 'em in a silk tie,
all of a sudden they may
be completely a psychopath.
In their heart, they're still a criminal.
We look at 'em differently
than we do the kid who has
three ounces of pot in a bag
that we throw into prison for two years.
Now, a corporation in this setting,
let's just say what it
is: They killed 11 people.
- [Interviewer] Right, right.
- For all practical purposes,
they created mass murder,
but still you can't find
people understanding
that they're criminals
because they look different.
They're from Wall Street.
They have a British accent.
They're dressed up in an Armani suit.
They have nice looking shoes.
They talk intelligently.
They have dinner with politicians.
They know celebrities.
And our culture doesn't
allow us to understand
that they're really just criminals.
- [Narrator] The year before the spill,
BP sales equaled $239 billion.
BP's total fines and settlements
were a meager 0.3% of this.
The oil industry is, by far,
the most profitable industry in the world
and includes six of the 10
largest corporations worldwide.
This industry is now
experiencing a level of power
comparable only to the
era of Standard Oil.
We are currently standing
at the crossroads.
The choices we make in the
next five years will impact
our future generations like never before.
Much of the technology and
expertise are readily available.
It's a matter of choice.
- When anybody could
convince 13% of idiots
to go vote for you, you could win.
The most disappointing part
of the American public is
that one of the few rights
you got left is to go vote,
and a lot a people just don't
take the time and don't care,
and look where we at, you know?
- [Narrator] We must summon the willpower
to force government,
corporations, and Wall Street
to become responsible for their actions
before we reach the point of no return.
- We just...
The future is up for grabs, you might say.
It really is up for grabs,
and we gotta do something about it.
And the only people that are
gonna do something about it,
you just mentioned, are
the people that care.
And that's most people,
that's most people.
Most people care about their country.
Most people care about this.
The dissidents and the
radicals get the exposure
from that press you were
talking about a while ago.
You have a peace rally in one corner,
and you have a war rally in the other.
Who gets the coverage?
This peace rally's not
gonna get the coverage.
The war rally's gonna get the coverage.
It's what people are gonna watch.
It's what the news, it's
gonna sell the newspapers.
We've got some changing
to do, young people.
- I was just talking to
my daughter yesterday.
I got on a long harangue
about all kinds of things,
hoping that they did a
better job than we (laughs)
than we do.
I'm hoping that our children
learn a better balance
with the environment, with the economy,
with the things you need
out of the environment.
There just needs to be
a better stewardship.
- Native elders say
that, you know, I mean.
If you listen to them,
they talk about the end-time prophecies
and all this kind of
stuff and they're like,
"Oh, everybody's saying
it's the end of the world,
"it's the end of the world,"
and this native elder says,
"The world's not gonna end.
"Humans, humans may end, but
the world will still be here."
There's an old Chippewa prophecy
from Sun Bear back in the '20s.
He said, "There will come a day
"when the Earth will shake
herself to rid herself
"of pesky humans like a dog shakes itself
"to rid itself of fleas."
You gotta look at the
things that are happening.
I mean, there's stuff happening around,
all around the world everyday.
- Beat something up enough, it
doesn't get up again, right?
You can exceed some threshold,
and that's what we always
are concerned about
with ecological resilience is:
Where is that threshold of impact
where the system does not bounce back?
We've seen this before.
One of the best examples is
Georges Bank, the cod fishery,
one of the most tremendous fisheries
on the face of the Earth,
and we fished it darn
near to wiping it out.
And there's still cod out there.
We backed off the fishing pressure,
but those populations
aren't growing, all right?
We've exceeded some resilience threshold.
They're not responding.
There's no resilience there
in the cod populations.
There's something that
we've done by going too far,
too much of an impact.
Have we done that to the Gulf of Mexico?
To even one part of it or all of it?
Have we exceeded thresholds
for the Gulf of Mexico ecosystem?
We won't know for year.
- It means that this generation,
that we pride ourselves in
being such progressives,
that we've changed so much
stuff, the Baby Boomers.
It means that everything we told them,
they have to ignore.
It means that all these promises we made
about how right we were,
we have to admit we were wrong.
Did we change come great things? Sure!
I'd love to say we brought
about Civil Rights to some degree.
We did, we helped.
I'd love to say that we gave women rights
that they didn't have before today.
Yeah, I'd like to say that.
We had a positive social impact,
but if you weigh the bad
decisions we made along the way,
if you weigh the
consumerism that ate us up,
if you weigh the culture that we built
that is around celebrity,
it's around celebrity.
It's around ideas that
don't really advance us
as a culture, they entertain us,
and we're able to say...
We're able to say we've
made some advances,
I suppose, as a culture
entertaining ourselves,
making ourselves comfortable,
building our houses, making our car.
We've done some good things, I suppose,
but we have to tell, I
have to tell my child
to ignore most of the things I've done
because if she doesn't
ignore the things we've made
as a Baby Boomer generation,
it's endgame time.
(pensive piano melody)
(dramatic foreboding music)
(typewriter keys clicking)
- They could burn in hell,
is the way I feel about 'em right now.
That's the way I feel about it.
They could burn in hell,
what they're doing to me now.
You know, hey, I'm fed up with it.
They could burn in hell.